Samantha's in Texas hi Samantha
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you
sure how can John and I help Connie
because I am getting married in October
thank you because I have about 37 grand
in my savings and I don't really have
any bills I still live at home I just
have my car note but how much do you owe
on their car well it's a three year
lease and I only paid 300 a month
okay so you got fleeced all right
that's least I was planning on
purchasing after my lease is over and
I'm going to school I have about two
years left so I wanted to know what to
do with my sleeping recessions are you
playing rattle I was going to use the
cash that I have I'm so thinking about
saving about 15 leave aside to leave for
school and then the rest I'm not sure if
I should put that towards our future
home he has schooled it as well okay
well you don't pay his debt until the
ring is on the finger and you're back
from the honeymoon you don't pay you
know people pay peoples debt you're not
married to yet and so 15,000 gets you
through school who's paying for the
wedding he is and our family is helping
and he's got that he does have school
that that he hasn't touched in a couple
years
how much 40 grand what does he make and
those I mean yeah he makes me need about
35 to 40 depending and what do you make
the same okay so you're going to $80,000
our household income when you get
married you will have $22,000 in the
bank that is left over from the 37 after
you pull 15 out for
your school and you have a car lease and
he has a $40,000 debt right well this is
what it looks like when you get married
in October if you don't do anything
between now and then you can't pay cash
for the wedding yeah yeah good point
I okay so we got to get you out of the
car lease and we gotta get his loan paid
off that's our next thing as soon as and
you both can start working on those now
once he's got wedding funded he can
anything above that he can he start
working on his debt and you once you got
school funded anything above that we
need to use to get out of this car lease
and get you a car that you own instead
of a three-year rental you are renting
your car bad idea and so you says three
hundred ollars a month and you got two
and a half years left on earth three
years left on it I have a year and a
half
Oh a year and a half yeah okay
yeah numbers aren't gonna work very well
with that much left on it's not much
left that's thirty-six hundred that's
four thousand bucks gets you through the
end of the lease
okay so here's got to be your plan then
at the end of the lease you're either
going to pay cash and buy that car
because there's a buyout clause at the
end of the lease if you want to buy it
do you think that's what you'll do or do
you think you'll turn it in my plan in
the beginning was to purchase after the
lease was over I did the lease because
the interest was going to be extremely
high for me since I didn't have any
credit for the way I started out that
way in the future you pay cash for cars
or you don't buy them car payments will
always keep you from being wealthy
they're the largest thing we buy that
goes down in value so we got to get you
to that point so do you know what the
residual value of the car is yet what
the buyout at the end the lease is it
stated in the contract do you have to
know what it is it is 13 pain okay so if
you're gonna buy that car you need 13 K
left over right yeah and you need 15 for
your school that got me to 28 out of 37
which means you got nine left to put on
his student loans after you get back
from the honeymoon
so something about like that is probably
gonna be your plans that make it sense
to you it is all I'm doing is making
everyone these dollars giving every one
of them an assignment that both of you
have and so if you throw ten at his 40
he's got 30 and you pick you pay cash to
buy the car out at 13 at the end of year
and a half which is gonna put you a year
into your marriage before the car is
gone
then you guys are just attacking his
student loan like crazy when you get
back from the honeymoon and very very
cool stuff